Instructor: If you
work on a team or an open source
project with other people, it's
helpful to have an ESLint file
right in your Git repo, and then
you can have what's called a Git
hook, which will not allow
anyone to commit any code,
unless it first passes the
ESLint rule. That's really
important because than you're
going to keep up code quality
for everyone that touched that
project. Let's do something
from scratch here. There's no
predefined folder you're going
to get. We'll say git init ES6
git, and we're doing this inside
of our 12th folder here. What
that will do is, it should make
a folder called ES6 git. We'll
go into that, and you'll see
that we have a clean master
branch now. Let's go ahead
and create a file that actually
has some bad code in it. Code.JS,
and we'll open up that file in
our editor. In here, I'm going
to say var x = 100. Then I'm
going to leave off that. Let's
do a couple bad things here.
Let's go ahead and say ESLint
our code, then it's going to
yell at us, and and here's all
the specific things. You'll
note that we don't have an
ESLint file in this folder, but
it's picking the one up from the
parent folder here, because that
how it works. It will always
check the parent until it finds
one. Now we're inside of ES6
Git, and I want to be able to
commit these files, but before I
do that, we want to make a hook
for this. A lot of people don't
know this, but if you were to
open up the actual Git directory,
watch what we get inside of here.
There is a folder in here.
There's branches and other kinds
of info, but there's a folder in
here called Hooks. If you open
that up, there's all kinds of
sample. Hooks in git are
essentially code that runs
before things happen, and you
can stop those things from
happening unless they pass a
specific use case. In our
case, if we open up the commit-
message-sample, this is an
example of something that will
run before someone commits their
code. What I want you to do is
rename this one to not Git
commit message-sample. Take off
the .sample, rename it there,
and then take out whatever we
have in there, and remove it.
Go ahead and copy everything
from this file, make sure you
get it all, not just forget to
copy the last line. That happens
a lot. Paste it in there, then
we're going to go to our Git
repo and say Git status. We have
code.JS. I want to be able to
commit it, so I say add
everything. I'm going to commit
it by saying "added new code."
Then, it's going to check. It's
going to run this code. Why?
This is a pre-commit message.
I'm about to add a commit
message here. It's going to run
our check and say "ESLint failed.
Git commit denied." Why?
Because it did not pass, we got
four errors here. What we have
to do is go back to our code
here, and we look at all the
different errors. First
error, unexpected var. I should
have used const. Then next error,
X is defined but never used, so
I should have said console.log X.
Infix operators must be spaced.
I forgot the space there, and
missing semicolon. I've got to
put a semicolon on the end there.
Great. Now if I add everything
that we changed, if I commit
everything now, it should check
against it, and look. We didn't
have any problems with our
ESLint, so everything went ahead,
and now my maste branch is in a
clean state.